when I graduate from universities for
three years I tried to fill in the
universities so I applied jobs for 30
times got rejected I went for a place
they said no you're not good I went to
either even the KFC when KFC came to
China come to I say 24 people went for
the job 23 people accepted I was the
only guy and we went for police five
people full of them accepted I was the
only guy that I receive it oh by the way
I told you that I would I applied for
Harvard for 10 times rejected ten times
he wrote them and said I'd like to come
to Harvard yeah and then I told myself
someday I should go teach everybody
he started his business with twenty
thousand dollars that his wife and his
friend helped him raise he's the first
Mainline China entrepreneur to be
featured on the cover of Forbes Magazine
he's the richest man in China and the
18th richest man in the world with an
estimated Fortune of 29.7 billion
dollars he's Jack ma founder of
alibaba.com and here are his 10 rules
for success
we have a secret code for Alibaba
success
just like open sesame is the secret code
for Alibaba the secret code for
everybody is keep your dream alive
because it might come true someday this
is what the secret code is what do you
think your core competence is I'll call
it is cultural
it's not the technology I think
technology is a tool the core components
of our companies we have 220
000 grow from 18 people to now 20 000
young people and we focus a lot on the
value in the mission and making sure the
culture everybody work for helping
others instead of instead of you know
just making money
people don't like it
so many people I talked to at that time
for alipay they say this is the
stupidest idea you have ever got but I
say I don't have the stupid Club as long
as people use it now we have 800 million
people using this early pay I learned a
lot of things from from movies I learned
how to make a speech from the movie
called
um Bodyguard Whitney Houston
when she sings the songs I look at her
wow that's the way that you make us
picture because I never know how to make
speech
because I'm not an actor
but when I saw the movie I said wow
if you sing from your heart if you sin
naturally if you are yourself
so I I realized and I learned a lot from
the movies you know even learned from
the Godfathers I learned my favorite
movie is a Forester gum you know these
uh these are the things I learned so
much that night we discussed about the
Muse The Inspirations we got from movies
what kinds of business ideas have you
said no to I'm saying no to a lot of
ideas because as a CEO I have to say no
to Opportunities because if I say yes I
probably get a 5 000 opportunities every
day but rather yes or no everything
based on the mission that will help in
doing business easier if it's on that
we'll consider if our somebody come and
say can you we will you don't have the
history will make a lot of money I'm not
interested why did you call it Alibaba
Alibaba
well when I started I think internet is
global we should have a global name and
a name that
interesting like at that time the best
name is Yahoo
right I think I can so I've been
thinking for many days suddenly Alibaba
is a good name so I I was happened to
being San Francisco that day and I did
have a launch and a waitress can I asked
you do you know about Alibaba she you
say yes I said what is Alibaba about she
said open sesame
good so I went on the street asked about
10 20 people they all know about Alibaba
40 thieves and open sesame and I think
this is a good name and start with a
whatever you talk about Alibaba is over
top
we believe that coconut is different
from the Wall Street We Believe custom
number one employee number two sharehold
number three customer one employee two
three yeah are we again this is my
religion and you know if you it's the
customer that pay us the money it's the
employees that drive The Innovation it's
the shareholder and the shareholder
always say you know I remember the day
before we IPO and a lot of people say
yeah can I give out the shares we were
long-term shareholders but when the
crisis came these guys
my people State custom State and I don't
want to tell the young people
but most people complain
where is the opportunity there is
people started complaining some people
complain some start people start to
change themselves changing others where
the opportunities is where the
complaints are where the trouble where
is the opportunity and I always believe
that
our team again
watch out
foreign
thank you foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 50 more amazing roles from
Jack ma check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I
remember nine years ago when I started
the alipay people say Jack don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison
if you want to be successful learn from
the